look here at the outdoor boys YouTube
channel and today we are dealing with
the aftermath of the three-story 200
square foot cardboard castle we built
there you go buddy across the drawbridge
yeah it's all it should be all safe you
like that we've got a lot of stuff to
clean up the boys have absolutely
destroyed the cardboard fort and what
you didn't see in the video is
everything that's normally in this room
was crammed into one corner to make room
for the cardboard fort so a little
behind the scenes there so we have got
to do some serious cleaning you want to
leave you want to leave this part up
this is the one part you haven't really
destroyed yet I'm gonna need these
fishing rod tubes back eventually though
oh you're on notice
[Music]
well guys we made some pretty good
progress but I think we got to call it
for tonight
it is late and I've got to get them to
bed especially that one
[Music]
well there we go we've got it all
bundled up ready to take to the dump
place is looking a lot better yeah boss
it yeah
[Applause]
well it's a beautiful Saturday and we're
gonna probably go hit the dump today at
any time have you been working out dude
you look ripped you got muscles on top
of muscles you show me do a flex for me
you got muscles too oh yeah
well let me see your profile there here
know what turn turning look at that
chest man ooh your massive now I've got
to decide what I'm gonna do with this
Saturday I've got probably half a dozen
videos that are in the works I've got a
story meat cleaver I've got a custom
knife the leather handle I've been
working on I've got some cast-iron pots
that I'm restoring and REE seasoning you
know we got tons of things I probably
have seven or eight videos in the works
and I need to come up with a cat's and
carp video to do let's see what we're
gonna do with today well I was gonna
take all this stuff to be recycled at
the dump but my office manager is moving
his house and decided he wanted to call
dibs and all these cardboard boxes
[Music]
I also have a lot of nasty like cold
mixed feel that I need to get rid of so
they got some hazmat stuff that I need
to dump so it won't be a wasted trip
all right nice you ready to do some
clickbait no curl up like a little ball
now sit down make yourself into a little
ball oh yeah you fit much easier feel
linked to the hobby down here
sailu the cameras in cheese all right
guys you ready to go to the dump
Oh does this mean daddy's gonna throw
you away you guys want to come back home
after we go to do the dub see if you can
get out of the bag I'd help them but
they'll never grow strong can you guess
which one of our children had to be
induced and which one came naturally
yeah let's go to those you'll get your
arms back when you burn them Tommy
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
whoa look at all those seagulls oh yeah
there is so many seagulls hi I've got
some gas can some hazmat stuff where do
I dump that and if I want to dump off
the two children where do I put them the
two Joe that's not on Saturdays you guys
have to stay in the car I'll be right
back just knocked over the gas can and
it just dumped gas all in here oh look
at that
oh it's gonna stink in here so bad look
at all those seagulls I saw there's a
bald eagle or two in here all right
we're gonna play a little baseball here
come on Tommy
sock it to me so uh it's a beautiful
sunny day it's only like 46 but it's
sunny and that helps it's been a cold
winter but I'm playing a little baseball
with the boys in between shooting videos
doing a video about restoring a antique
cast-iron so I'm gonna like electrolysis
bath and vinegar and coca-cola and some
other stuff and now I'm just sitting and
waiting so I'm doing that playing with
the boys and the best part is Becca
actually gets to go outside and see
sunlight yay and look even Jacobs
hanging out with us
I like how Nathan plays vet baseball
they had no hitting the picture at the
back right it's scary Nathan made the
things baseball is a mix between MMA and
polo no I won't defend okay go woo
this is how you play baseball you fight
off the other team who are attacking you
with bats don't hit Nathan you'll go to
a timeout from which you'll never emerge
[Music]
oh man
like I was impressed you guys just ran
right in there you want to sleep at this
bag you know people are gonna start a
GoFundMe page for for the Nichols family
helped Tommy afford a coat careful you
don't want the leaf snakes to get you Oh
leaf snakes are terrible they slither
around underneath the dry leaves and
they go up your diaper and bite your
bottom well did you get bit by a leaf
snake did get oh let me see let me see
Oh your bottoms swirling way up I know
mine is 16 years well that a project
took a little bit more time than I
expected it's about 5 hours of grinding
and scrub in on those cast-iron pots but
I got to a good stopping point now I
need to go get the kids some dinner and
I'm gonna go take my wife out on a date
this is kind of a typical weekend for me
I spend about 8 hours working on video
projects and the rest of time messing
around with my kids and occasionally
what I'm lucky I get to do both at the
same time it's if you ever thought about
doing YouTube videos just remember it's
a lot of work I've been doing this for
about 4 years now and just posted my
fifth five hundredth video and our door
boys just hit 50 thousand subscribers so
not bad for its first year thanks for
watching we hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you'd like to see more great
videos from the outdoor boys youtube
channel don't forget to click Subscribe
we put out new videos every week and
don't forget to hit that Bell button so
you'll get notified when we put out
another great video